and if you look at too many
civilizations throughout history I think
a lot of the the Terminus point is when
when things start going bad is when
they're too comfortable and they need to
create a crisis for themselves maybe
they don't even realize they're creating
a crisis this is why Elon Musk is the
most important human being right now
there are two paths before Humanity one
where we've we've got no perceivable
problems because we have tons of food
we're fat and we're lazy this means that
humans technically don't have to do
anything we can go down that path and
that path involves breaking down Society
destroying everything or we can
recognize the problem we face is just
that finite space and resources with a
gluttonous population and the solution
is colonization of other planets that's
the path I think we need to go down
because the problem we're facing is the
gluttony and laziness and lack of
purpose of humans so we need a purpose
and we need a way for humans to expand
interplanetary travel and colonization
Elon Musk is doing that with Starship
they just did a major test on it they
collected a bunch of data
who else is doing that